I am what scientists refer to as an
American Homo American and as an
American I like a select few things I
like freedom I like money I like boobs
I like boob freedom with money I
probably shouldn't be shouting that I am
in Korea by the way don't know if I
mentioned that to anybody but I am in
fact in Korea but as an American in
Korea my mind always goes to one single
thing that overrides all of my base
instincts for survival such as water
and/or shelter and or five breathing as
an American there's one thing I love
above all else and that is a good
old-fashioned American hamburger what I
have here is not a good old-fashioned
American hamburger but what this does
contain is the other distilled essence
of what America is all about
capitalism that delicious sweet
delectable somehow like a demon in the
night McDonald's has chased me all the
way from America here to my apartment in
Seoul but inside this bag is a mystery
because I asked how is Korean McDonald's
different from American McDonald's so or
is it different at all
and I can tell you already that it is in
fact different because the ordering
experience was a little bit different
you see McDonald's is trying to
implement these cashier list order
takers known as computers and these
computers decide your fate instead of
fairly interpreting it through spoken
language and until I can shout my order
at a computer I'm not gonna trust it as
much as shouting as a he had a huge and
an underpaid human being
in all honesty it wasn't that much
different than an American McDonald's in
terms of the ordering procedure
here's a few shaky videos that I took
wallows in McDonald's
[Music]
they're really bad because I'm not a
professional vlogger and I'm not good at
busting out my camera in public because
I'm embarrassed
which is weird cuz I'm pretty much not
embarrassed about anything else in my
life I will literally do anything I
won't do I take that back completely but
the McDonald's wasn't that bad it was
clean it was a bit crowded but the order
came out quickly and I ordered a lot of
crap and buy a lot of crap I mean for
some reason I thought I was I know what
I ordered like I only ordered the
equivalent of about 25 bucks worth of
stuff but for some reason my brain
thought it's just gonna be pulling us
slim bags and bags of McDonald's onto
the table and that is not the case but
what I did ordered is a sampling of
different sandwiches and different board
ORS or as they call it in Korea hen
Vogel licks in do you know how to
translate that good so what I have here
is an assortment a variety a different
assembly of different tastes some that
are replicas of burgers that you would
find in America and some which are
original burgers that you will only find
here in Korea and I'm going to taste
them and use my encyclopedic knowledge
of McDonald's food I am well versed in
the ways of McDonald's I've been eating
it since I was a young boy I'm not proud
of that fact but I do know my way around
a McDonald's menu just throwing it out
there and I'm so hungry I'm Sal they've
never thought so first step first
the cornerstone of all McDonald's the
pimp daddy no it's breaking the first
bit of soil when you're building a new
skyscraper you always have this ceremony
that's digging into it where all the
executives who don't get paid minimum
wage to move dirt around decide to put
on a bunch of hard hats just I don't
know why there's not even anything above
their heads yet but they put on a bunch
of hard hats they get a big ribbon
they cut the ribbon with giant scissors
and then they dig a hole with the
tactical shovel and I don't know why
those two are juxtaposed against each
other but that's just culture business
culture capitalism it's delicious you
wouldn't understand if you don't have
money anyway this is the cornerstone
what didn't I just say that from the
beginning this is the cornerstone of
McDonald's their french fry this is what
they're known for
besides all the burgers and the possibly
destroying the environment with the meat
industry but that's besides the point
this is what they're known for and the
heart attacks and general overall
diminishing of the human body's
capability to repair itself this is what
they're known for
if it wasn't very clear I'm not
sponsored by McDonald's and I will
continue to [ __ ] on them despite the
fact that I'm a hypocrite and I enjoy
their food okay right off we have a
problem
this is soggy the taste is there the
taste is there but the texture is gone
one thing that McDonald's is known for
is to just really crispy not crispy
crispy not like crunchy crispy but it's
got a snap to it
not bad but it is soft and and what's
weird is they taste fresh which says to
me this is just how these fries are now
I might be mistaken this is only one
sample size statistics are out the
window but from my anecdotal evidence
this is subpar the taste is there like I
said well there's a limp dick fry if I
ever saw one but this is what you can
visually see how this has no snap to it
because it's a limp dick fry that's a
tasty limp dick though not bad what
chewy
maybe it's better funny maybe it's not
as deep fried
maybe it's healthier I lie to myself
next up we have McNuggets if there was
ever something that showcased mr.
McDonald's egotism and narcissism it was
put it's putting Mick in front of
everything McNuggets these are just
chicken nuggets but they're now
McDonald's patented chicken nuggets by
putting them in there they're no
different but is this shape there Oh
interesting okay so the shape is there
if you didn't know these are completely
artificial in every way I'm not 100%
sure if they're from pink slime and you
know they're fake because they have four
distinct shape they have rectangle they
have boot it doesn't look quite right
and I know my way around it McNugget
they have circle I guess okay I seem to
be missing some because there are four
distinct shapes I know this these are
the shapes you can look them up normally
when I get it I always get spicy buffalo
ranch and barbecue they didn't have
barbecue they didn't have spicy buffalo
but they did have this thing called
Cajun so that sounds pretty good that
smells like it smells like spicy mayo
you get a sushi place when you're me and
order everything with spicy mayo and
then ruin the sushi by dunking it in
there and then dunking it in soy sauce
or in Korean as known as ganja
I'm an [ __ ] is basically what I'm
saying but first I'm gonna try it by
itself now there's a crunch is it weird
of me to want to describe this more as a
biscuit or a cook than a McNugget
because that's what I'm getting out of
it it's got a much crisper much drier
texture but it doesn't taste like that
dry texture that I would get from an
American McNugget that I hate this is
good mmm
doesn't taste like chicken no it tastes
like nothing this tastes like cardboard
but it's a pleasant experience see this
proves that I'm purely a texture based
eater I love the flavor of mushrooms but
I cannot stand eating a mushroom just
because the texture as well
I like the flavor of many goopy gushy
things but the texture is awful
I can't do it this is a fine texture if
I do say so myself
tastes like cardboard but I'm okay with
that because I'm a basic [ __ ] and I
have no requirements for quality
speaking of which what is your favorite
shape because each shape has I swear to
God
each shape has a different flavor I
can't prove it because I have no
scientific way of proving taste but I
swear each shape of the McNugget has a
different flavor I'm just I'm not lying
about that I'm not joking I'm not
exaggerating please if you know what I'm
talking about
please back me up because I feel like
I'm great I've never asked anyone about
this I've never said it out loud but
I've always thought this each shape has
a different flavor if you believe me if
you agree with me back me up and tell me
that this is not the boot but the boot
has the best flavor it's just a fact and
I it's a fact I can't prove but I know
it's a fact which is it how facts work
right that's out good work yeah on the
internet it is so this is the Cajun
sauce it's got like a horseradish kick
to it it's not bad despite the face that
I made do it in urban flip replay the
face it's got like this horseradish kick
it's it's this but it's a spice but it's
not like a capsaicin spice it's a
horseradish spice or wasabi spice it's
not bad I go back for more but our first
it was unpleasant cuz my my brain didn't
know what was going on I don't like the
sauce very much it's not matter ah
napkins I guess I could be reviewed they
don't have the McDonald's logo imprinted
on them which makes me very sad because
I definitely like the white Mike oh they
do it's really subtle okay I'm happy now
okay a stable I'm living with like the
normal stuff first and then escalate to
the more
Kurian types of food that they have here
this is just a quarter pounder with
cheese or as in Karina says quote tall
pound all TD there's a lot of words in
Korean that are simply American words or
words from all around the world better
and this didn't smash into the Korean
dialect okay so it's got all the basic
ingredients the burger doesn't look too
happy but you know maybe it'll be
happier when it's in my mouth because
that's its purpose purpose sex tastes
like home the meats a little a little
bit rub more rubbery than what I'm used
to and I'm pretty sure that most of
these burgers only contain about like 20
percent rubber this one might be in like
25 30 percent rubber but taste is very
much like if I was getting a burger in
America this would be a burger that I
would think had been sitting there for a
little bit longer than it should have
but I'd still eat it because I'm like
I'm driving or something like that or
it's 3 a.m. and I've got nowhere else to
turn to and I pull in with shame in my
eyes and sweat on my brow and I got pit
stains and I greasily look over the
cashier in hand of my soggy credit card
and then they take it and look at it for
a few minutes as if they've never seen
the credit card before cuz 3m and they
don't care then they slam it in the
machine then they don't hand me my
receipt they throw it in my general
direction because I can't look at me and
I can't look at them either so I hope to
catch it and if it walks away in the
wind then so be it I never needed my
receipt in the first place not a shuffle
off to the next one oh I don't because
it's the same window so instead of
shuffling off to the next window I just
sit there in my car I don't know whether
to roll my window up or keep it down you
know I don't know if it's rude to keep
it down and look at them or maybe you
have to roll it up maybe that's rude cuz
like I'm cutting off and then I gotta
put it back down again for them to just
give me my food and I never know how
long it's gonna take biggest three am
its crapshoot whether it's gonna come
out in two seconds or two hours so I
just sit there kind of like thinking
about reaching for the
window Rolly up B and then I eventually
just rolled the window and then right as
I do then they bring out the food and
then you know my word is wrong so I I
don't bother to check because at that
point I just like my body only need
sustenance in one way or another it's
either that or start chewing on the
steering wheel and to be honest but my
mouth wouldn't know the difference and
then I show I Drive off into the night
and consume and park under a bridge
[Music]
anyway we're good
it's not bad and the onions are rich I
might come back to that I know this
seems like a waste but as I said in the
beginning of the video I'm an American
and waste is pretty much all of our
middle names mothers try to finish
things I'm gonna try this will be like a
mukbang which is that Korean thing where
they record themselves or live from
themselves eating an ungodly amount
which I'm I do I guess we're not so
different after all
even they get orders wrong cuz I'm
pretty sure I ordered a chicken sandwich
apparently I didn't there was another
problem with the the interface the
computer was slow so I felt bad making
everybody wait for my collar
it's all breached I don't know what this
is about but okay so I'm not typically a
Big Mac guy when I go to McDonald's I
usually fall for the quarter pounder or
the double Quarter Pounder depending on
how much I hate myself in that
particular moment but I like the Big Mac
it's not bad but I do know it's not the
best value because these are the same
patty as they put in their double
cheeseburger in their make double why
would anybody get a double cheeseburger
when they could just get him a double
the only thing that's missing is a slice
of cheese and I'm not gonna pay 40 cents
more for a slice of cheese when I'm
already paying a buck 39 for a McDouble
not miss it back in the day when he was
the nine and nonsense meal home
hmm no that's rubbery um
the special sauce it's not that special
I think it's just like mayonnaise and
ketchup and some other schmutz
but these patties are just plastic and
the lettuce is kind of sad a little ol
little dehydrated yeah doesn't have much
water left in it
pickles are fine hmm no run that pickle
was no fun so that's the first
disappointment I've had I don't
default the Big Mac but I like the taste
of a Big Mac and that is just not that
big and not that Mac that being said I
hate myself I would finish this and I
will try to but I'm gonna wait till the
end
so this oh no this is the jig I did give
I forgotten because this one's called
the mix spicy Shanghai burger and I feel
like someone should be insulted by that
name but no one seems to be raising a
fuss about it so I guess I can't really
say anything other ones but anyway so
this is the one that's chicken do what
what the hell this lettuce is green that
tastes fresh what kind of lettuce do
they put in this they made it at the
same time why does this have fresh and
that has not fresh so this is basically
a McChicken chicken sandwich deluxe my
guess is it says make chickens Shanghai
but it seems to just be
that's what I get for being me and
existing in the first place okay it
seems to be chicken a tomato slice and
lettuce much better lettuce looking than
that lettuce I don't usually go for the
chicken deluxe sandwich because I don't
like tomato we'll see what happens
that's a tasty bite hmm that is a oh
that is a tasty bite and taste fresh I
think it might be the good lettuce and
not the old stinky cabbage oh oh I do
like that I got nothing else to say it
doesn't taste Korean like so far nothing
here is tasted Korean everything just
tastes in varying levels of quality
which is amazing considering all these
were made at the same time but I'm
assuming that's all just due to the
different way it's cooked in the
different sources of ingredients this
tastes good very good I think the in
Korea they just have better sources of
chicken than they do have beef because
they just don't have the space for raise
cattle so all the beef has to be
imported I believe okay I got nothing
else to say about it I'm still sad I
think they like the edge pieces were
usually safe bet just saw okay so this
is where things get Korean cue the
Korean music and Lexy and if you put on
something offensive sure I got people
come after you better not be Chinese
better not be Japanese Korean and not
Kate stop not kpop just don't put on
anything but on the old music whatever
it was Scott this one is called the blue
Goldy burger now bulgogi is like Korean
barbecued meat
it's basically Korean BBQ is
colloquially known as like a restaurant
that does stow in the center of the
table and you cook the meat yourself
it's delicious if you haven't gone to a
Korean barbecue place go over there
Gogi is basically barbecue beef Kogi
means beat blue means fire fire meat
barbecue meat it's kind of the same I
don't know if I'm under Sun on that one
but that's what I kind of generally
understand about it so this one has meat
bulgogi sauce you can kind of think of
it like a teriyaki but it's not teriyaki
it's got an egg in here it is just
drowned in sauce which I love I love
sauce there's also cabbage here there's
gonna be a weird mixture of flavors and
I don't know how I'm gonna handle it but
man here we go that's fascinating I
can't say it's the best thing I've ever
had but that is just a fascinating
combination of flavors that tastes
distinctly like Korean food I've had
around here if I put on a blindfold that
I went down to the street corner and I
got some Korean food from some random
schmuck I wouldn't mistake it for this
burger that's not what I'm saying but
the flavor profile is very distinctly
Korean and it has to just be the sauce
right I mean also the lack of ketchup
maybe it's the lack of what I'm
expecting at a burger that's more
surprising than the addition of anything
else because when I try hamburgers
there's always mayonnaise ketchup
mustard depending on the burger hello
new episode of edge of sleep available
now also new bloke here
available now links in the description
the flavor was so intense it stopped the
recording on my camera
conclusion it was good but not that good
I didn't like it that much it might have
been an acquired taste if I managed so
much footage alright and also you missed
my outrage because I didn't get another
item that I ordered called the corn pie
what is a corn pie you might ask frankly
I don't know I don't know if a corn pie
is something that's supposed to emulate
something from America or if it's Korean
thing just seemed like a green thing
because I've never seen a corn pie here
it was right next to the apple pie now
an apple pie I know and I know that
Koreans have good apples but I don't
know anything about the corn and I
definitely don't know anything about the
corn pies and also I know for a fact
that Koreans are not known for their
pies because Koreans don't typically
have ovens that's just a thing you like
Koreans for the longest time you know in
their history they didn't have ovens
they didn't bake a lot of things so
there's not really any basis for them to
be a corn pie but I'm never gonna know
because I didn't get my corn pie because
I ordered it buddies up so it's not yeah
so I will do without and I will make do
with the last thing on my menu and I
even did a dramatic reveal of me going
to get this thing am i record I bet I'm
not recording right now I even made a
dramatic flourish of getting this thing
out of my freezer over there because if
there's one thing that I get from
McDonald's more than anything else it is
a McFlurry
this is Korea's McFlurry now there's a
weird difference here right off the bat
it's got this fact which is very
convenient I guess
seems like a waste of plastic and I'm
not about wasting plastic because of the
sea turtles and everything else in the
ocean I don't know why this is here but
it's good for carrying I suppose but
also it could be good for carrying if I
just pad a cup with a lid but I don't
I've got a bowl question mark either way
so what this is is a salted caramel
McFlurry sounds pretty good to me I
really like this truth waffle McFlurry
that they brought to America for a
little bit from wherever stroopwafels
are made so I'm assuming that this is
going to be pretty good what's weird is
the salted caramel isn't even them it's
got the names of the different flurries
here but it's not even listed on here so
maybe it's a new thing I have no idea
okay whatever pop that's Pleasant
experience just want to get the smell
deep inside my nostrils okay there's one
thing hard to get wrong its sugar sugar
is pretty much ubiquitous across any
country it crosses over borders it
crosses over boundaries this has sugar
in it and it's tasty because my brain is
a basic [ __ ] and when it gets sugar it
screams and runs and shouts out how much
it's in love with whatever is getting
the sugar inside of my body there are a
surprising amount of things that the
human body will do for sugar and there's
a surprising amount of things that sugar
does to the body and return mostly bad
things sugar is probably the worst thing
you can put inside your body and yet
here I go because it tastes so good then
again that's probably why people do
heroin the ice cream is not the same I
have not gotten a lot of ice cream while
I've been here in Korea but the ice
cream is fundamentally a little
different now that supposed to say it's
bad it's just different
it's not what I would expect when I
would get say an ice cream cone if I'm
walking around amusement park or a
McFlurry I don't know if it's just a
different way they make it or if it's
the different ingredients or if it's
different mix or different cows or what
it is or different milk committees milk
I don't know but all I know is it tastes
a little bit different that doesn't mean
it's worse still tastes good and there's
mmm it's good I just inhaled something
dust it's probably fine this is good I
don't see how it could be bad that's
what I thought when I ordered it and
frankly I'm kind of confirmed on that
assumption it is a McFlurry and all i
McFlurry is another bunch of [ __ ] thrown
into ice cream that's what this is
conclusion the wheels of the corporate
machine don't stop no matter what
country it is in wherever it finds
itself and wherever it's able to dig its
claws into it will spread its genes far
and wide and the Apple will not fall too
far from the proverbial tree so the
Donelson Korea is not that different
from McDonald's in America if you are an
American and you like an American
hamburger you probably aren't eating at
McDonald's but if you are a basic [ __ ]
like myself and find yourself going to
McDonald's more times than you would
like to admit this is not a bad place to
go because it's not bad over all the
staples that you would find in America
tastes almost the same except for the
fries that's this point but what can you
do maybe that's just a fluke it might
just be a fluke I've had wildly
different fry experiences from
McDonald's in America so might just be a
fluke
the Nuggets pretty good the Big Mac
ring that Bell